morning John one of the things I saw a
lot mentioned in the census as I've been
reading through it is that people want
to hear more about our adulty lives
doing the things that we do and another
thing that I know just about the world
is that we celebrate our own successes
and other people's successes we don't
talk about failure at all and it's kind
of a taboo topic it's hard to ask other
people to talk about their failures and
it's hard to talk about your own it
makes it feel like failure is unique and
when you experience it like no one else
ever has because no one else has ever
talked about it well John as you know I
am currently in the midst of something
of a failure I have this company that
aims to celebrate nerdy things in the
world by taking them off of the internet
for a little bit of time and into the
real world
VidCon of course being nothing started
this all off but we also want to
celebrate other nerdy things that people
are passionate about in particular I
started nerdcon stories because stories
are this amazing thing that defines
culture it's how we build our culture
how we decide how we're going to talk
about ourselves in our world and this is
the way in which nerd kind of stories
this year will not be a failure sold
about a thousand tickets which means
that there is going to be a huge diverse
interesting group of people celebrating
storytellers and story there's a ton of
community generated and community
focused content it's not just about the
big names that are going to be there
it's about all the people who are
attending the conference all being the
reason that all of the people who are
there are attending we budgeted the
conference to have 3,000 attendees
that's how many we sort of needed to
make it work financially we have a
thousand so at this point in our con
stories which I as a human person own it
stands to lose a lot of money now I can
afford this the nerdcon is not gonna go
bankrupt I'm not gonna go into debt it
does sting I'm learning a lot through
this whole process but I do wish it was
a slightly less expensive set of lessons
I talking about it not a good feeling
that's why people don't do it you want
to portray to the world this image of
like are so good at it but not nobodies
like that nobodies lives are like that
last year nerd cam stories was such a
wonderful experience for me and I'm very
sad that I can't be there again this
year especially since it's probably
gonna be the last time nerdcon stories
happens and I think this year it's gonna
be a fantastic time for everybody who's
there and really that's like isn't that
the thing that matters if you'd like to
attend the event or even just check it
out see maybe if you'd like to it's in
Minneapolis and I know lots people can't
go for all kinds of very good reason
just to say to you make sound financial
decisions you right
you are your first responsibility but if
you're interested in checking it out
I've we've created a discount code on
dftba 20% off 20 bucks off because you
know what do we gotta lose I'm not proud
that I made a bunch of you know thought
errors or just misunderstandings of how
this event could go and I might make a
video over on Hanks channel discussing
all of those mistakes so that you don't
have to explain them to me in the
comments I I know and I'm very proud of
the idea of this thing and the thing
that we put together and I'm very glad
that it's going to be a thing that
happened in the world we've got John
Green yoga adventure happening one
morning we've got opportunities for
in-depth conversations with professional
authors gaming community sourced content
a live episode of dear Hank and John
though the Hank isn't going to be there
workshops on jeans puppetry improv
podcast and panels on diversity
adaptation even tabletop gaming as I
list these things I totally get that
nerd con stories is a really weird event
and that probably doesn't work in its
favor this is among the mistakes that
were made but it's also kind of the
reason we're not gonna pull the plug on
this thing I've got to keep it alive
we're gonna do it even though it's gotta
lose me a bunch of money this show must
go on because it's different and I think
special maybe that's the thing that we
could all be going for like we're all
gonna fail sometimes we're gonna make
stuff and it's not gonna work even when
we fail is there a way to eliminate the
shame of that and instead make it a
failure you can be proud of John I'll
see you on Tuesday I'm a bit mama be
okay video and Hanks channel more more
in depth